all right so we're here to talk today
about kubernetes for developers so quit
show hands first off how many people
have any experience with kubernetes
previously okay couple everybody else
how about dr. how many people have
experience with docker a few more okay
good so my name is Jeff French I'm
principal consultant at moon switch
we're at DevOps and cloud migration
consultancy and we specialize in
kubernetes so if you need any help with
that let me know so let's start by
talking about what is kubernetes
kubernetes is a comes from a class of
product known as a container
Orchestrator or a container scheduler
those terms get used a little bit
interchangeably they tend to actually
mean slightly different things and that
a scheduler typically is a little bit
less full-featured than an Orchestrator
but we'll get into what that actually
means when it actually orchestrates your
application so kubernetes is not the
only player in this space they have
there are other schedulers and
orchestrators including docker swarm
that you may have used apache meso /d
CLS is kind of based on mesos and hashey
Corpse nomads are just a few of the
other container orchestrators and
schedulers that are out there and they
all do relatively the same thing right
or versions are the same thing so a
container Orchestrator first often we
say container we're typically talking
about a docker container there are other
container technologies out there that's
well beyond the scope of this talk and
most of these orchestrators have the
ability with some modification to
schedule things other than docker
containers or docker compatible
containers but the job of a container
Orchestrator is to take a set of
instructions that you give it that say i
have some set of containers that
represent my application that i need to
run and i want you to run them for me
right
I don't want to be bothered with you
know figuring out is there room on this
I don't know ec2 node over here and go
over there and run a docker run command
to get my container running and then if
my container crashes having to go and
say uh well let me go start that
container back up or you know upgrade it
to a new one or something like that
that's the orchestrators job so that's
what kubernetes really does for you it
manages a set of nodes that can run
containers and it schedules containers
to run on those nodes and it does a lot
of things that are you know as far as
depending on how your cluster is
configured it will move workloads around
to you know balance them between nodes a
little more or consolidate them more on
nodes so that you can kind of downsize
your cluster so these are all the kind
of functions of a container Orchestrator
and what it does so there's two sort of
sides on how you need to on how you need
to interact with a kubernetes cluster
one would be the operator side where you
are typically a sysadmin or DevOps
engineer who is in charge of standing up
all the nodes and joining them into the
cluster and making sure they stay
healthy and all that we're not covering
any of that part today today this is
about if you are a developer who wants
your apps to run on a kubernetes cluster
here's this is kind of a quick start on
things that you want to actually know
and we're gonna scratch the surface on
some things this is a gigantic topic and
there's a ton of documentation out there
on the kubernetes website and lots of
blog posts I'll try to kind of hint at
when there's more things you might want
to research on your own we're going to
keep this at a pretty high level intro
level talk so the first piece of
vocabulary we want to talk about in
kubernetes is called a pod okay so a pod
is a collection of containers and
volumes so if you've worked with docker
before you know what a container is
right it's basically you've taken your
app or some code that you've written and
put it into this nice little portable
container that can be run somewhere else
wherever there's a doctor engine you've
probably also dealt with volumes if
you've dealt with docker which is
essentially defining
a disc that's going to be attached to
that doctor container so if you think of
a doctor container as a virtual machine
because it almost is then a volume would
be like a disc that you're going to
attach to that virtual machine where you
can store some data and have access to a
disc so in kubernetes we deal with pods
and as I said it's a collection of
containers and volumes that you define
now typically a pod will have ideally
one container that's not always true but
you have one main container that runs
your application and that's kind of the
core of a pod is here is my web app
running in this docker container now
there are you can have multiple
containers inside of a pod depending on
what you need there one common usage is
something you call an init container so
let's say that before your actual
application needs to can run you need to
actually you know do a little bit of
pre-work before that happens maybe
there's some secrets or configuration
that's mounted in on a disk somewhere or
coming in from environment variables and
you need to arrange that into like a
config file that your main container is
going to read so you could have an init
container that spins up first and the
way the kubernetes handles that is it
spins up your Indic container it waits
for it to successfully complete and then
it spins up the main container for your
pod the other interesting use for having
multiple containers in a in a pod would
be what's called a sidecar which means
that you have another container that is
sort of an auxilary container inside
your pod that's doing something
out-of-band from your main app so one
example for that might be say a logging
container say your app just logs to
standard out and maybe you've got this
sidecar container that's kind of sharing
a process space with your main container
that's scraping those logs and shipping
them off to an elk stack somewhere or
something like that so that's one common
use for sidecars or having multiple
containers in a pod
however you could actually have to you
know what you might consider primary
containers in a pod one example that
I've seen referred to a lot is like
let's say you've got your main app in
this main container is serving some
files from a file system so you've got a
volume mounted in it has these files on
it but these are also files that need to
be updated regularly so you might have a
second container that's running inside
your pod that is just in the background
constantly checking some other source
and syncing these files into the local
volume while your main container is
still serving this web application
that's provided that's serving those
files so that's another scenario where
you might have multiple containers in a
single pod but typically when you think
about a pod you're generally going to be
thinking about it as one main container
and that sort of represents your unit of
work so let's look at a pods back so
kubernetes
all interaction with kubernetes
basically is handled through a
kubernetes api but they've got a
command-line tool called cube control
that you can use to do most tasks
against the API and a very common method
of doing that is loading what are called
manifests that are typically written in
Yamma but can also be written in json
and essentially what ends up happening
here is cube control will take these
yamo files convert them to json and send
one to the API in order to tell your
kubernetes cluster to create certain
resources so when you're looking at
cribbage you're going to see a lot of
gamal and it's a really nice way to be
able to express what's going on so let's
look at this pod in detail here this is
a very simple pod it's got some metadata
attached to it namely it's got a name so
it's my app - pod and then it's got a
label which says oh this label says that
the app running in here is my app the
labels are freeform there's no actual
required or standard labels in
kubernetes although there are a lot of
convention based labels that people will
apply and you can think of labeling if
you've worked with AWS or Google Cloud
or anything like that think of it like
the same way that you would have as
tagging right so if you're creating a
ton of AWS resources it's a common good
practice
to tag those with some consistent and
convention based tags so you can easily
kind of see what you've got running
easily issue bolt commands against those
things the same principle applies with
labels in kubernetes right they're a
great way for you to be able to keep
track of the different resources that
are being deployed in order to support a
given application so then we look at the
spec in the containers and you'll see
that obviously the the containers here
is a Yambol array so you can list
multiple containers this one just lists
one and it's called my app container I
define the docker image that it uses
which is just the busybox docker image
but that can be pulling a docker image
from any docker registry where you've
got your docker hosted and that your
cluster has permission to pull from
we're defining a command for it to run
which this one is obviously just a real
simple kind of echoing out hello now we
look below that and we see that we've
got volume mounts so what I've done here
is we have got a volume defined down at
the bottom of this pod and it says hey
here is this is a very simple volume
it's a volume type known as a host path
which basically just takes exactly what
it sounds like
a path on the host that is running this
container which is one of your
kubernetes nodes and makes that
available as a volume that you can
attach to these other containers there
are a ton of different types of volumes
that kubernetes supports right out of
the box like probably thirtyish
everything from AWS EBS disks Google
persistent disks you know set for
Gluster FF file systems NFS mounts I
scuzzy if there's a way to attach a disk
to a VM there's probably a way to
support that in kubernetes to get it
attached to your pot and make it
available as a volume so in this we've
got a really simple on the host at slash
data we've got this directory that
directory has to already exist there's
another directory type that is directory
or create so it will create it if it
doesn't exist and then if we look back
up in the container spec we can see on
the volume mounts that we've told it hey
take that volume that we called test
volume which is a host path
and make it available inside my
container at this mount path of slash
test - PD right so that means that now
my doctor container this busybox image
it could read files or write files to
and from that mount path you can also
make volumes persistent you can define
within criminalities persistent volumes
which say hey this this volume should
outlive my pod right I don't want this
data to die when my container goes away
right if I shut it down and spin up
another container I want to make sure
that I've still got the same data there
I don't want to lose it and so you can
do that through persistent volumes and
persistent volume claims which are not
included on this spec but something else
you might want to look at as you
actually start looking at running real
workloads on your kubernetes cluster
okay great so we've got pods sure so do
I have to define that all the time well
most of the time you won't actually
define a pod directly you'll define what
is known as another class of resource
known as a controller and the most
common controller that controller type
that you will deal with in crew Burnette
ease as a developer is going to be a
deployment so a deployment describes the
desired state of a set of pods and
manages updates to those pods so what
that means is if I want to define this
pod and a set of volumes and everything
that's all fine and good but I might
need to run more than one of them right
maybe my app is popular and I need to
run five web servers to handle it well
rather than creating five different pod
specs with different names on my own and
managing those I can create a deployment
so with the deployment you can actually
define the number of replicas that you
want to have running at any given time
and when the deployment actually starts
running what it does it says okay I
should have this pod running and because
you've set replicas to three I know I'm
gonna make three copies of it and and
distribute those out and it's probably
easier to explain that by looking at a
definition of one so
here's the definition of a really simple
deployment so we've got again our
metadata section where we can give names
and labels and that's all fine and good
but then the interesting part becomes
this spec so this is what's known as a
pod spec and it follows the exact same
schema as the pod that we looked at
previously but it's going to be it's
going to be managed by the actual
deployment so under our spec we say I've
got replicas of three and this is a to
run a simple Engine X pod that's going
to serve web traffic for my app so the
templates here are interesting because
this metadata that's under the template
over here this is going to actually be
applied to the pods this whole template
is a template for the deployment to
create its own pod specs as needed based
on the number of replicas that you've
requested and then we've got our same
spec and this has really simplified down
to just a single container here but we
could have volumes mounted here we could
define environment variables that need
to be passed in so in the background a
deployment actually creates another
kubernetes object called a replica set
and before deployments were around
replica sets were like the recommended
way for you to run a set of pods that's
no longer the case now you know the sort
of recommended guidance is not to create
replica sets yourself in most cases but
instead to create a deployment which is
again a defined you know a desired state
that you wanted to have and so then the
kubernetes api is going to say okay cool
because you've expressed this desired
state I'm gonna make sure that I'm
always keeping it in that state and
doing whatever I have to do if I see
that there's only two of your pods
running and you've requested three
replicas then I will spin up another set
of pods to match that the so when you
actually spin these up they get
distributed to whatever nodes are
available and the deployment handles
that for you and it says okay great you
want more of these you can have more of
them and then the nice thing about a
deployment is it becomes a way to manage
your scaling as well so if
you were running three replicas and all
of a sudden you start getting hammered
with traffic you can issue a simple cube
control command to scale up this
deployment to ten replicas and it's
going to go out there and handle that
for you say oh okay great I see I've
already got three I'll go spin up seven
more for you
let's get those going and we'll get into
a little more detail about some of the
scaling features toward the end of the
presentation so great we've got a
deployment and this deployment is now
managing all these pods that are running
my app awesome I need to get some
traffic to that application I need to
send users there to do things typically
I mean not always you may have a
non-interactive workload that's just
doing Bitcoin mining or something but
typically you're going to run web-based
applications on the crew but I just
Lester I need to send traffic to them
well a service routes traffic to a set
of pods so this is basically a
definition sort of it'sit's called a
service because it is used for service
discovery so that you can say I need to
send traffic to this pod but I don't
necessarily know the name of that pod
because the deployment may have killed
and created multiple pods there may be
10 pods running but I need to just
reference it I don't want to just load
balance between those so that's where a
service comes in and when you create a
service there are a few different types
of services that can be created the
default type of service is called
cluster IP and what that means is that
this service gets assigned an IP from
The Cider block that is internal to the
cluster a cluster IP service is not
exposed outside the cluster at all it's
only accessible by other things that are
running inside the cluster another type
of service is called a node port service
so when you declare a service of type
node port you will specify a port on
each one of the nodes that is going to
be listening and proxying traffic for
these pods and so what it will do is if
you say
expose a service of type note port on on
you know port 33 602 then every single
node in your cluster is going to expose
that port and route that traffic to your
pods based on the definition of your
service and then the other type of the
other common type of service that you'll
see created is called load balancer now
what this does is it actually typically
integrates with whatever cloud provider
or other system you're running your
kubernetes cluster on so let's say
you're running in AWS and you create a
service of type load balancer it's
actually going to go out through the AWS
API and create a ELB that is going to
route traffic to the nodes in your
cluster so in this case now we're
actually exposing this to something on
the outside world a node port does this
as well where you're saying hey these
nodes if they're accessible somewhere in
your VPC depending on how you have
things configured will actually route
this traffic now when you're dealing
with routing traffic inside the cluster
a service actually gives you a very nice
convention if you have which most
kubernetes clusters have kubernetes dns
enabled internally so what you end up
with is a dns name like this whatever
the name of your service is whatever the
namespace that it's running in and then
dot cluster dot local so if I have let's
say a database server running in my
kubernetes cluster and I it's maybe in
the data namespace and it's called
Postgres then I could have a name of
Postgres data dr. dot local and if I
want my other apps within the within the
cluster to be able to access that I can
just feed them that name and the service
is going to take care of always routing
that whenever new pods come up and old
pods go down the service actually
handles routing the traffic to those
based on a set of rules that we'll look
at here in just a second but my other
applications that are consuming that get
this nice static predictable dns name
that they can reference inside the
cluster
so here is a simple service definition
so we're defining a service its name is
my service it's got a selector here
right so this selector section is
interesting because this actually
interacts with the labels that we saw on
our deployments and our pods so what
this selector is saying is that the way
that I want this service to route
traffic is by looking for all pods that
have a label of app with a value of my
app so this is how the service is able
to kind of dynamically route traffic as
your pods get spun up and spun down by
the scheduler if we look at this we're
defining the port's that we actually
want to route traffic to so in this
we're just routing simple port 80 and
port 443 to a target port so this target
port is going to be the port on which my
actual container inside my pod is
listening for these types of traffic so
I'll have my doctor container inside my
pod listening for HTTP traffic on port
93 76 and this service is going to
listen on port 80 and direct that
traffic over to the other port
okay so with the exception of the
service type load balancer we just said
that the services don't actually expose
things to the outside world by default
the cluster IP service doesn't a node a
node port type does but it's very
difficult to manage because it's going
to be these random ports that are on
three five a hundred a thousand of what
how many nodes are in your kubernetes
cluster so how do we get traffic from
the outside world in as we said there is
the load balancer type which will
actually create a load balancer in
whatever cloud provider you happen to be
running your cluster in that can get
expensive real quick if every single
thing that you especially if you're
running on microcircuit x you're with
you know 30 or 40 you know web apps that
all need to be exposed all of a sudden
you're going to be paying a lot more for
those DL bees than the value they're
actually providing in most cases well
this is where an ingress comes in so in
kubernetes and ingress is a resource
it's referred to as a resource even
though it doesn't actually do anything
an ingress simply describes a set of
hosts and paths that should be routed to
a given service from outside the cluster
to the service that's inside the cluster
they don't actually do anything by
themselves because they actually employ
what is known in kubernetes land as the
operator pattern where there is a
ingress controller or operator that you
install in your cluster that actually
follows these instructions that are
defined in the ingress so really common
one would be like nginx ingress which is
going to spin up an engine X instance or
instances and basically read these rules
and say okay great you route all the
traffic to me as nginx and I will
automatically dynamically configure all
these backends to route traffic to
within your cluster so let's take a look
at an ingress here is an ingress that
I've used to expose a gitlab web UI in
my cluster to the outside world
now there's a few new concepts in here
an interesting one here is the
annotations annotations are valid in the
metadata of pretty much every kubernetes
object they differ from labels a little
bit and that labels have to be very
simple key value pairs
whereas annotations can be more complex
as we see here with you know having
actual URL style identifiers annotations
are typically used to tell some other
thing how it should interact with this
kubernetes resource so in this case some
of the interesting ones here are that
we're saying okay well the class for
this ingress is engine X that means that
I have deployed the engine X ingress
controller in my cluster and I'm saying
hey I want this ingress to use the
engine X ingress controller there are
ingress controllers that are there's one
that's specific to Google compute if
you're running in gke there are there's
one called traffic there's I believe
there's actually an H a proxy ingress
now and you could actually run multiple
of these in your cluster if you wanted
to and this annotation helps them decide
which one of them should handle your
ingress another interesting one here is
this TLS Acme I'm telling it hey I want
you to get a TLS certificate an SSL cert
for my ingress in this scenario I've
deployed another controller called cert
manager that knows how to interact with
let's encrypt so whenever it sees that
I've created an ingress with this set to
true it says hey cool I'm gonna go in
there and I'm gonna read the data out of
your ingress and I'm gonna go interact
with let's encrypt automatically issue
you an SSL certificate it's a lot of
really interesting things can happen
that based on these annotations the
actual ingress itself is specifying that
hey for this given host I want you to
route the this path to this back-end
it's very if you've ever configured
engine X or H a proxy it's a very very
familiar type of concept where you're
saying hey when you see this come in
route it over here to this back-end
server transparently to the user pass
along some IP data
like that in the headers this does the
same thing so I can actually have this
this is passing all traffic at the main
route path but I could have it say just
you know slash users if I wanted to
route that to some different service for
a reason I can also have multiple rules
to find in here if I need to but and
this is telling it this back-end is
telling it the name of a service so just
as we saw in our previous example of the
service I'm telling it which service to
route to so you can see we get this kind
of multi-tiered thing where we're saying
okay an ingress helps me define how
traffic comes into the cluster and goes
to a service then a service helps me
define how traffic that's already gotten
into the cluster gets to its ultimate
destination on an actual back-end and
then in the TLS section this is just
defining a little more data about where
this SSL cert would be so in this
scenario we would end up with a
kubernetes secret called get lab get lab
TLS that would have a couple of keys in
it that hold the private key and the
public cert that were obtained from
let's encrypt and make that available to
whatever ingress controller is trying to
run this such as our engine X instance
so let's look at what all that looks
like right so based on what we've talked
about so far we have this is a
representation of kind of what we just
went through which is that we've got
traffic that's out here in you know in
the internet that get arrives at some
hostname that we've defined via external
DNS that hits our ingress so in this
case let's say our ingress is the nginx
ingress controller so it's hitting an
engine X instance and that engine X
reads its own config and says cool
because you came in on this host and
path I know that you want to go to a
particular service so it routes that
traffic down to the service once your
traffic hits the service the service
says ok great I know how to find the
pods that you want to use and I'm gonna
send you to one of them and it just cuz
basically a round robin DNS at that
point where the traffic now hits one of
the pods that I have running in order to
serve that traffic so this is sort of
the basic application setup that you'll
see for most things that you deploy into
kubernetes especially as a developer and
application developer a lot of times
we're building web you eyes or ap eyes
and this is going to be a really common
paradigm for how you actually get
traffic to your application that's
running inside of the kubernetes cluster
so
so now that we've got our actually tired
of standing behind this podium if I can
move just a little bit without messing
up the twitch stream so now that we've
got our application running as a
deployment how do we update it right
this is one of the reasons why you use a
kubernetes deployment instead of
directly using a replica set or pods
yourself is that the deployment has a
lot of options that help you manage how
you actually roll out updates to this
thing so whenever I come in and say ok
we've shipped version 1 of our app to
kubernetes as a deployment now we've got
version 1.0 point 1 ready to go because
we found a bug and got to release it so
when I go and actually update say the
image tag that I'm deploying for my
docker container of this deployment
kubernetes sees that says ok great well
now that you've made an update to this
deployment I'm gonna look at your update
strategy and figure out how it is that
you want me to roll this out the one
option that it has is recreate in that
scenario it just basically goes and
nukes all of your pods and recreates all
of them with the new definition that's a
way to go there's probably a good use
case for it I haven't had a good use
case for it yet because typically I'm
deploying apps that are actually in use
so the default is a rolling update
strategy which means it's going to based
on a set of rules look at all the pods
and say ok cool I'm going to go through
and upgrade them systematically until
I've got them all done and when you're
doing that you can define one of two
types of strategies there is the max
unavailable and then there is the max
surged and these aren't exactly mutually
exclusive except that if one of them is
set to 0 the other one can't be and
we'll get into that just a little bit
but what we've got here is if we do
unavailable than what we're saying is
that a certain number of my pods can be
unavailable at any given time during
this update and that's okay and you can
express that as either an absolute
number of five pods or you can express
it as a percentage like twenty-five
percent of whatever I've got deployed I
usually find a percentage to be
something that scales a little better
when you actually start scaling your
deployment up and down you probably care
more about the percentage of total pods
than the actual exact number when so the
other type is a max surge so a max surge
defines a number of pods that can be
running in excess of what you've defined
for your deployment so if I said on my
deployment that I want to have five
replicas then a Mac surge says that so
many pods can be above that number
without it actually without the
deployment starting to kill them off as
oh hey that's more than what you asked
for
so let's look at this a little more
detail with an example so let's say I've
got on our on our web server engine X
replicas set to ten saying all right
Cooper daddies I want to always have ten
pods running serving all my web traffic
so in the scenario where we have defined
a max unavailable of three here I've
chosen an exact number despite the fact
that I just advised you with percentages
just for simplicity for simplicity sake
so in this scenario it means that once I
tell kubernetes to update our deployment
it will say okay cool well you've got
you've asked for 10 copies of this to be
running and I've got a max unavailable
of three so I'm gonna go kill three of
your pods
and update them to this new spec and I'm
gonna wait until they come online before
I do any more all right so it starts
those updates and you know one of them
might finish before the others so as
soon as one of them finishes then
kubernetes says okay cool well I can go
take down
another one of your pods that needs to
be updated right and at any given time
it's gonna make sure I still have seven
available and and at least seven
available and no more than three that
are not serving traffic now in the max
surge scenario we go the other way it
says okay you've asked for there to be
ten of these pods running and I'm not
going to take it any lower than that
instead because you've got a max surge
of three I'll bring up three new pods
and when they're ready I'll start
swapping those in to your set of ten and
swapping out your other ones so in that
scenario we might go as high as 13 pods
that are active and serving traffic and
which one you choose really kind of
depends on your application and your
constraints and you know whether it's
more important to keep more pods up and
serving traffic or if it's more
important to stay under a certain number
so that you're you know cluster doesn't
get overloaded you know one thing to
consider is that whenever any of these
schedulers like kubernetes are trying to
schedule their pods they look at a few
different things to say hey is there
enough CPU and memory on this node to
put this pod there and if there's no
place to put it then those pods just sit
there and never get spun up right so
that might be a scenario if you know
that you typically run sort of at the
capacity of your cluster for whatever
reason then you might want to choose a
max unavailable update strategy so that
it starts pulling pods out and and
freeing up those resources before it
creates new ones if you've got plenty
and a Headroom on your cluster and it's
more important to make sure that you've
got enough you know pods serving traffic
then you might want to go with a max
surge where it says okay great I'm gonna
make sure that I'm always got enough you
know 10 pods running to serve these
customers but I'll scale it up as high
as 13 in order to get these updates
rolled out
yes so the the the only real exclusivity
rules that apply to these according to
the documentation and I haven't done a
ton of experimenting on these two and
practice to see how they actually play
out in really large scaled scenarios but
is that if machs unavailable is set to
zero then max surge cannot be zero and
vice versa if max surge is set to zero
then max unavailable cannot be set to
zero right you have to allow it to do
one of the other or it'll just be
deadlocked and can't do anything now if
you define both of them again like I
said I haven't done a ton of
experimentation in this scenario but
what I expect would happen is that it's
going to basically work within those
limits so in this scenario if I had both
of these things defined then it's going
to start creating pods and killing pods
as it needs to and the rule said it's
evaluating against is okay am i above
seven and you know below thirteen and as
long as it's in that range it's free to
start creating and killing pods all that
it needs to
okay so there are there are several
other ways that you can run pods in
kubernetes we covered a deployment which
is a way of just essentially keeping
things running based on some describe
state right other other things in the
same family as deployment would be
stateful sets and daemon sets which are
a little bit less common and a little
more advanced we're not going to get too
deep into him here suffice it to say
that if you have a daemon set it's like
a deployment except it means that it's
going to run rather than a number of
replicas it's going to run that pod that
you define on every single node so it
has a one to one relationship with a
number of nodes and your cluster if you
do a daemon set that's typically used
more for things like logs scrapers and
aggregators or things like that where
you're kind of monitoring health usually
or anything else that you need running
on each node exactly once a stateful set
is similar to a deployment except that
it makes some guarantees around identity
and ordering of your actual pods and
that's more commonly used for things
like databases where maybe you've got a
leader and you know two or three
replicas and which one is the leader and
which ones are the replicas is actually
very important in that scenario and you
need to make sure that there's a certain
amount of availability and that things
are rolled out in a certain way and
those are two things that you can dig
into a little bit more if your workload
if you think that you need that for your
workload typically your user deployment
however another class that you'll
actually use quite a bit as a developer
is a job so it's similar to a deployment
in that it describes a set of pods
except with a job it runs it once to
completion for each pod that you define
and usually it's one pod it could be
multiple and you can do some interesting
things with parallelism and queue queued
workloads but a really typical example
for using a job would be database
migrations right
whenever I deploy a new version of my
app I want to make sure my database is
migrated to match that version so I can
create a job and that job says okay
great create this pod based on this pod
spec and run it until it completes
completes successfully so what that
means is if it goes and starts my job
and this pod runs but for whatever
reason let's say the database is
unavailable or something else happened
and it couldn't actually run the
migrations and complete them
successfully that pot is gonna die and
it's going to get restarted again and
it's gonna improve Reggie's is going to
keep trying to do that until it
successfully completes once
now once you've actually run that
database migration you're like cool I
don't want to do that anymore so it
stops your pod exited successfully
indicating that it was done and it
completed whatever it was trying to do
and now that's it you're done
so that job just sits there and it's it
just sits there in a completed state you
can go back and inspect the state of it
and then you can delete the job if you
want it'll clean up any pods that it had
left laying around in a non running
State so let's take a look at a job
again we see that the spec looks very
very familiar albeit tiny that we've got
this essentially the same kind of
template it follows the same template as
the pod spec for a deployment and other
things and the only real difference here
is that because the kind is set to a job
and there's a few other things like a
back off limit that can tell it how much
it needs to back off from jobs or that
it should stop trying to run them if it
fails four times then just don't bother
trying anymore but it's very simple very
simple definition of a pod with the
caveat that it's only going to run once
now another sort of extension in the job
family is actually the cron job so the
cron job is kind of a controller type
object which says hey based on some cron
expression just like you would expect I
want you to create jobs for me so if I
create a cron job that has a you know
has a cron expression that tells me to
run
I don't know once every night at 2:00
a.m. then once every night at 2:00 a.m.
kubernetes is going to try to create a
job it may not succeed in that so it's
there's not as a firm of a guarantee on
cron job execution as there would be
with say just traditional cron on your
system but it's going to create a job
and try to have that job run and it's
going to do that every night at say 2:00
a.m. which is a great way to I don't
know backup some files or a database or
something like that or perform some sort
of maintenance task so those are jobs
and cron jobs and then so I promised
we'd get back into some of the scaling
stuff as that is one of the interesting
you know sort of promises of kubernetes
and the cloud right is is that you can
scale things you know to meet demand and
then you can scale them back down when
you don't have demand and save some
money right so from the developer side
one of the ways that this happens you
can obviously go in and scale a
deployment yourself if you notice a
spike in traffic you can go and issue a
command that says scale this deployment
up because I need more pots but do you
want to watch the dashboard all day to
find out that there was a suddenly a
spike at 3:00 a.m. and you needed to go
issue that command manually probably not
instead you can use a horizontal pod
autoscaler
so this will scale out a deployment
based on observed CPU utilization or
other metrics and I probably should have
put an asterisk after that or other
metrics because that part gets well
beyond the scope of this talk suffice it
to say that you can actually monitor
different metrics such as the number of
you know hits coming in on an ingress or
you know disk space or something like
that right
but we'll just talk about them in the
simplistic form of CPU utilization so
let's say I'm running this app and this
app is starting to you know that the
aggregate CPU usage across all of my
pods I've got say I've got three pods
running and
they're at they're averaging out and
they're aggregating up to you know 80%
or 90% CPU utilization and I say oh well
we're busy we better scale up so if I've
already defined that in a horizontal pod
autoscaler then the kubernetes api is
already watching that for me and it says
oh hey we've hit the threshold add some
more pods right scale it up take it from
three to six you know and you can set
the definition on what your min and what
your max is and which metric you're
tracking and the way you do that is with
this cube control command it's really
hard to see sorry but basically it just
says cube control Auto scale deployment
you give it a deployment name you tell
it you're watching for CPU percentage to
be above 50 and I want a minimum of one
and a maximum of ten so what the
horizontal pod autoscaler is going to do
is it will scale your pods up or down
based on these observed metrics so if
we're running above 50% CPU and we need
more pods it's going to add those in and
then later when the the wave of traffic
has subsided and our aggregate CPU usage
is down it's going to start scaling
those pods back in as well right now
this becomes really really interesting
when you deploy it with something that
would be more in the operational side of
a kubernetes talk which is a cluster
autoscaler so there are cluster auto
scalars for let's say you know Google or
AWS or something that will say hey
whenever kubernetes is trying to
schedule these pods and it says hey I
don't have anywhere to put these right
like I'm all my nodes don't have enough
CPU or memory to support this pod that I
need to schedule so it's just pending
then the cluster autoscaler would see
that and say oh well let me add some
more nodes to your cluster you know
through an auto scaling group or
whatever else and it goes out and puts
more nodes in the cluster and then all
of a sudden the you know the scheduler
can now find a home for those pods so by
and then the cluster artists Keller does
the same thing in that periodically it
says hey well we've got more capacity
than we need let's consolidate some of
these pods on to a couple of nodes and
take a node out
using this you can finally kind of
realize the the true elasticity of
today's you know modern cloud
environments where based on observed
metrics that your application cares
about you can now dynamically scale up
you know to as big as you really feel is
necessary or need without human
interaction just let the machines watch
the traffic take the action based on
rules scale it up now you're handling
enough traffic and then when everything
dies down all of a sudden it scales back
in so you're not paying for all that
capacity you don't need so once you get
into horizontal pot Auto scalars and
cluster Auto scalars you really get the
true kind of promise of why people want
to use things like the cloud and
kubernetes in order to actually run
their workloads alright question and
answer time if you've got questions I'll
try to give them answers and yes
oh yeah so yeah so the question is does
it when a service goes to route traffic
to a pod does it look at the load on
that pod by default no I think I saw an
option or it may have been some sort of
an add-on that could do that but by
default it just does simple round-robin
although I believe you can configure
sticky sessions so that could that could
come into play as if it knows that a
particular pod is is not is overloaded
with concurrent sessions so the question
was does the when you go to execute a
rolling update does it also take traffic
away before it does that so yes and no
right in that it it's going to go kill a
pod which means that that pod is gonna
immediately be March before it even gets
killed it kind of I mean this all
happens like that but it's going to
actually mark the pod as unavailable
which means that the services that try
to route traffic to it say I only route
traffic to available pods so they're
constantly every time they need to route
traffic they're saying all right well
where's the list of available pods that
one's not in it so I won't route any new
traffic there now if you have a sticky
session that was routed there I don't
actually know what happens with that but
that's essentially how that works and so
while it's not explicitly making
decisions like oh I should take away
traffic for this it's it's sort of this
composition of all these other rules
that we talked about that dictate how
that's how that traffic is going to flow
right right so the so to clarify yes he
was saying that it's not going to
necessarily wait for all connections to
be drained off of a pod before it stops
sending traffic there yeah so and and
again this really this comes down to you
know a term that has been getting thrown
around a lot lately about cloud native
and designing cloud native applications
and that really becomes part of a right
like in a cloud native application you
should be prepared to handle that
scenario for your customer where you
know this you know at any given time the
thing running my application code could
get cut off and I need to make sure that
my clients on the other end has some
kind of retry or that it's okay that
that connection be dropped right and
that's going to be very very application
and even particular in point or request
dependent to figure out but it's
something that you should be thinking
about as a developer who's going who's
designing applications to run on these
cloud native systems yep I mean the
question yes
I'm sorry okay so yeah the question was
how do you stay highly available with
your ass when you have to upgrade
kubernetes itself this gets a little
more on to the operational side of this
but essentially because kubernetes is
filled with nodes and node pools what
you would do is you would simply add
more nodes and then that are running the
newer version of kubernetes and the
cubelet api and your other nodes that
have apps on them there's a few series
of commands that you can run you can you
can cordon an ode which basically says
hey don't schedule any new work on here
but leave the work that's already there
running and then you can also drain a
node which tells kubernetes to start
taking work off of that node and finding
another place to schedule it so
typically your path there would be add
some new nodes cordon and drain your old
nodes and you know at whatever pace
makes sense for your application and so
that it kubernetes will then start you
know taking those pods off and putting
them on to the new nodes and they can't
reschedule on to the old nodes because
you've already cordoned them all right
any more questions no all right well
thank you very much again i am jeff
french with moon switch if you need help
with DevOps canoeist integration
kubernetes cloud migration moon switch
comm get in touch we'd love to help you
out and I have a few t-shirts and
stickers here to give away so if anybody
wants a t-shirt or sticker let's see
here I've got a size XL t-shirt any
takers
I've got a size large t-shirt yeah go to
this side of the room make sure this is
the large all right and then I think
that leaves me with a medium anybody
take a medium there you go very excited
for the medium also I'll have some
stickers just sitting up if anybody
wants them come on by grab a sticker
decorate your laptop all right and
that's all we've got for today thanks
very much
[Applause]